all right it's time to play a little
would you rather with big cat
let's get right into it would you rather
if you're jerry jones lock dak prescott
up to a long-term deal or
sign tom brady
chase a championship and take your
chances after he retires
this one's actually tough
because jerry jones clearly desperately
wants to get back to the super bowl it's
been a long long time
i still think i would take my chances
with the guy who's 26 long term
then tom brady fought you know a new
system a new setting
and
you don't know what it's going to be in
two three years whereas dak prescott
should
should be hitting his prime in those two
three years you know michael irvin got
this talk started on friday he was on
weei in boston and he said some very
significant people air quotes very
significant people told him that the
cowboys may make a run at tom brady he
had to put out the fire on social media
the next day saying none of those people
are with the cowboys well it doesn't
change the fact that he said some very
significant people told him watch dallas
as a landing spot for tom brady so look
i hey if i'm jerry jones
and
jerry jones has made it clear over the
past five years that he's keenly aware
that he's only got so many more football
seasons to try to to engineer in a
championship and
for one year
for this year i love dak prescott and
they should pay dak prescott but if this
is one year if if this is it if i got
one year to live and i'm jerry jones and
i know
that that i'm going up or down a year
from now
i am taking tom brady for one year for
one to try to get to try to go out with
a championship i want tom brady over dak
prescott did you i mean but he doesn't
have one year i would assume he doesn't
have one year i agree with you if the
hypothetical changes to one year jerry
jones has one single year i'd agree with
you but if you're saying hey jerry jones
might have 10 15 i don't know how old
jerry jones is modern 78 i mean he's
going to have all the modern medicine at
his disposal he's 78 okay
let's say 12 more years okay
you got to go with dak prescott you got
to actually have a little foresight here
and not just rush for the one year
i i here's the other thing that we need
to factor in we're going to move on to
the next one but we talked earlier about
dak prescott's contract situation at
some point there's a degree of
exasperation that can set in for the
cowboys if dak prescott continues to say
no no no no and want more more and more
more than what the cowboys are willing
to pay him that's a factor in this as
well at what point do the cowboys say
enough we'll tag him we'll trade him and
we'll sign tom brady all right if you're
ron rivera would you rather stick with
the quarterbacks you have or try to get
your old quarterback from carolina into
the fold in dc
i think you know
i cam newton is better than dwayne
haskins that's not like earth-shattering
news
but if you're ron rivera and you know
that the redskins used a
uh you know big asset a high round or
high pick on dwayne haskins you'd be
better served to have that become
something then go with cam newton this
year and
i mean if you go with cam newton this
year you're basically saying dwayne
hassan's is not going to be a franchise
quarterback so i think
again the long-term play here would be
to say let's see if we have dwayne
something with dwayne haskins instead of
trying to do a short-term fix short-term
band-aid with cam newton
yeah their concern i think with haskins
is he's going to feel like he's entitled
that the job is his and maybe he doesn't
bust his butt the way he would if he
were competing they're trying to create
an atmosphere of competition even if
it's not real and i think it helps
rivera in a weird sort of a job security
way to be skeptical about haskins but
embrace him ultimately because then if
you go a year or two and haskins isn't
the guy
it's easier for you to stick around for
year three and year four because you can
say hey dan you know i was on record
from day one i'm not a big believer in
dwayne haskins but we couldn't just
waste that draft pick so we went ahead
and gave him a couple of years now let
me go get my guy whoever ron rivera's
guy ends up being so you know i've seen
coaches go along with the status quo
knowing that they're not going to be
blamed for failure if they just make it
clear they have their doubts about the
guy and then they see who they can get
at quarterback later on i'd stick with
the guys i have i don't know the cam
newton wants to be in washington and if
i'm ron rivera you know for the same
reason the panthers may have
cam newton injury and health fatigue i
definitely have it if i'm ron rivera
right this constant question of is my
quarterback healthy will he stay healthy
should he be playing you know they let
him play the first two games of the year
when he had no business playing like
where is the person who says to cam go
sit down that's rivera's job i think
rivera's may be happy to to be away from
that dynamic all right uh next one if
you're tom brady would you rather
lose a super bowl without bill belichick
or
win another one with him
i mean this is kind of a silly question
isn't it would you rather have
another yeah but this one truly like
would you rather have another super bowl
or not have another super bowl i think
tom brady would take half another super
bowl
but but to get to the mountain even if
you don't win
to get there without belichick
i guess you know here's the question if
you lose to belichick
if you're losing to belichick in the
super bowl you don't want that that's
that's different right but seven super
bowls come on i mean that's crazy i yeah
the losing to belichick
would be
would be the interesting like making
this actually an interesting
hypothetical here
but but then listen don't don't poo poo
the hypotheticals right you come on
control room ninja style here
here here's the thing um
i i
i think that at some level
this this this stuff that's happening
between the patriots and brady
ultimately is driven by
brady wanting to show he can do it
without belichick and belichick wanting
to show he can do it without brady right
you've you've been on this for a long
time and and while there's probably some
truth to it i think it's very overstated
but you fit you admit there's some truth
to it of course it's human nature egos
come into play guys i mean working with
someone for that many years it's a
testament to how like great they are
that they have been able to make it work
because every relationship falls apart
eventually when you're in this type of
high pressure
you know situation where you have to win
all the time and people are handing out
credit that's a very very hard spot to
be in i just think at the end of the day
there's probably a lot more mutual
respect for each other than mutual
animosity if that's a good way to put it
well and let me say this i've yet to
answer the question i agree take the
super bowl win right tom brady always
says when he's asked what his favorite
ring is he says the next one he always
wants that next one and he wants seven
sims theory has been he wants to get to
seven because seven is one more than
your guy michael jordan so then at that
point people start saying tom brady he's
not just the greatest football player of
all time the greatest professional
athlete of all time because he's got
seven and jordan's got six
what about uh
what about
bill russell
well
don't listen don't confuse what about
with facts
yeah i'm sure there's a soccer player in
the like modern good mode he shoots his
scores uh all right if you're if you're
tasting mill
would you rather oh he's in the outline
would you rather wait another year in
new orleans with sean payton as your
coach and then you become the
quarterback in 2021 after drew brees
retires assuming he comes back or
start at quarterback somewhere else in
2020.
okay mike i have a question for you it's
a very simple question do you think sean
payton is a good football coach
yes
okay do you think teddy bridgewater is a
franchise quarterback
no
okay there therefore
what was
sean payton doing when drew brees got
hurt and didn't put in
future franchise quarterback that's mike
florio saying that taysom hill and
instead putting in not franchise
quarterback teddy bridgewater here's why
once you make taysom hill the
quarterback you can't use him for all
that other stuff this okay
but he's a franchise quarterback mike
he's a franchise quarterback hey listen
sean you've been waiting all week you
think you're going to put me in a box
with that i just put you in a box
you make no sense it's so simple if you
think sean payton's a good head coach
and you think that teddy bridgewater
isn't a franchise quarterback then
you're saying that sean payton will like
willingly
put in a lesser quarterback
under the under the the assumption that
taser mill is a franchise quarterback
like you said he willingly put in the
lesser quarterback to win games when you
had a franchise quarterback ready to go
on the roster according to mike florio
again i don't think tyson mills a
franchise quarterback that's absolute
insanity
well first of all it worked they won the
five games that has nothing to do with
it no no no the the results it's not the
results it's at the moment in time do
you think that if sean payton actually
thought taysom hill was a franchise
quarterback he wouldn't have put him in
there and said i'm playing the best guy
the coaches in the nfl always play the
best guy in that situation
let me go next level
okay
okay
we got to consider taysom hill's
contract situation
no
no no look they already have to worry
about somebody potentially making him an
offer as a restricted free agent and
sean payton told peter king super bowl
week they're bracing for that somebody
in the lower part of round one
making an offer for taysom hill and then
the saints have to decide can they and
will they match it they don't want to
lose this guy they found this guy this
is one of the great discoveries of sean
payton's career and he wants to keep him
and if you showcase him for five weeks
when drew brees is out and he becomes
steve young and sean payton is the one
who says the vision for taysom hill is
steve young are you kidding me and sean
payton is not a guy who recklessly
engages in hyperbole once you put that
steve young label on the guy that tells
me you believe in him and jake laser
reported during super bowl week and if
you want to doubt jay glazer i'll let
him come put you in a headlock and you
know he'll do it he reported that they
view
taysom hill as a franchise quarterback
and taysom hill views himself as a
franchise quarterback it astounds me i
look and it makes me wonder whether the
mouth breathers on twitter even pay
attention to what's going on in the nfl
because you throw out this idea like i
did the other day that taysom hill is a
future star in the nfl and these people
lose their minds have you not watched
taysom hill play have you not given it
did you not watch him in the preseason
against the chargers the guy has the
potential to be an nfl starting season
and when you're pre-season when you're
tied up i actually i said preseason did
i not say precedence no i know i'm not
repeating it no i'm ready for everyone
pre-season yeah okay pre-season i'll
stipulate that it was the pre-season my
point is this you put a guy like that
with sean payton you put a guy with that
skill set with sean payton the biggest
concern is keeping him healthy because
he had injuries at the college level can
he stay healthy as a full-time guy at
the nfl level but i look i don't know
what was going on inside sean payton's
brain when he decided to go with teddy
bridgewater over taysom hill because i
thought at a minimum it would be a
shared arrangement between bridgewater
and hill but
hill is the guy they envision taking
over for drew brees when drew brees
retires and if drew brees stays expect
to see a lot more taysom hill this year
and hill said it himself he views
himself as a franchise quarterback and
if the saints don't view him that way he
has to leave six that's simple
six careers
completion i know
hold on mike let me ask you this explain
this
explain this to me mike explain this to
me mike what how many passes did steve
young have behind joe montana mike he
seem young was a starting quarterback in
the nfl before he went to the 49ers what
are you talking about oh with the tampa
bay buccaneers i'm sorry was that did
that not count is that pre-season he was
stuck he was stuck you're crazy yes
you're crazy mike mike give me this
question get into this question what
happens if someone else goes and pays
for chasing hill do the saints get
anything in compensation they get a
first round pick
what they're gonna
what wait so if they wait if so
the first round hold on are you saying
then it probably benefits sean payton to
pump up tasa mill and put aaron why
would he is that where he's so why
wouldn't he have played him so you're
saying he didn't listen big cat did you
watch the vikings saints game did you
watch the saints of course i do you're
watching it i know you're lying he had
gimmick plays and he's a very good
weapon he's not a franchise quarterback
he's a complete six passes i just
dominated you in this
you know
i've got four fingers here
i've got one i'd really like to show you
right now listen this is a dream job
that i don't want to become a nightmare
no no mike all joking aside i absolutely
100 percent
wipe the floor with you in this argument
okay all joking aside
we all joking aside uh
never mind we'll be back right after
this with more pft
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports